das dauert zu lange bis die nötigen
maßnahmen ergriffen werden
wir befinden uns in einer situation in
der die regierung nicht die nötigen
konsequenzen gezogen hat
man hat den eindruck dass die regierung
die krise nicht sehr gut bewältigt
zögern zaudern durcheinander frankreich
taumelt in die zweite corona welle eine
der schlimmsten in europa dabei hatte
die regierung die bürger zu den waffen
gerufen gegen das virus
wir sind im krieg mit den harten worten
kann man eine harte ausgangssperre und
das versprechen das land entschieden
durch die krise zu führen
doch bald zeigt sich dass der krieg
nicht so leicht zu gewinnen ist
schwierig das virus ist noch für mehrere
monate da und wir müssen lernen damit zu
leben
neben der rhetorik verändert die
regierung ihre methode bald heißt es der
französische zentralismus führen nicht
zum ziel
wir haben in der ersten phase oft gehört
dass nicht alles in paris entschieden
werden kann alle regionalchefs und
regionalen gesundheitsämter werden nun
in absprache mit den bürgermeistern
beteiligt doch als die infektionszahlen
nach dem sommer wieder in die höhe
schnellen verhängt die zentralregierung
für einzelne städte eigenmächtig bar und
restaurant schließungen ohne die
rathäuser zu beteiligen
wir verstehen gar nichts mehr weil
unsere stadt im grunde ein lockdown
verordnet bekommt ohne dass dies mit uns
abgesprochen wurde
mangelnde absprache führt zu
unverständnis führt zu protesten
hier in marseille wo mehr als 260 von
100.000 einwohnern infiziert sind drohen
stadtbedienstete die von der regierung
verhängten restaurant schließungen nicht
zu kontrollieren einzelner
restaurantbetreiber sagen nein zur
schließung
ich habe noch vorräte und gehe das
risiko ein
wir haben familien zu ernähren alle
restaurantbesitzer sind in derselben
situation
es ist nicht das einzige beispiel wie
zentral und örtliche behörden
gegeneinander arbeiten mit steigenden
neuinfektionen stolpert paris in eine
allgemeine masken pflicht auf den
straßen
die masken pflicht gilt für alle
fußgänger und alle zweiräder und wie
elektro roller am tag darauf die
kehrtwende die polizeipräfektur hat auf
unsere argumente gehört und auf die
radfahrer organisation jogger und
radfahrer sind von der masken pflicht
ausgenommen hin und her
zurück bleibt eine verwirrte
öffentlichkeit die bezweifelt dass die
behörden wissen was sie tun und die nur
zögerlich mitzieht
die menschen haben den eindruck dass auf
sicht gefahren wird und die maßnahmen
sich immer wieder ändern
sie denken nicht dass die regierung
realistisch handelt im gegenteil es
fehlt ein klarer kurs es fehlt ein
klarer anführer und die große
befürchtung der franzosen ist dass es
eine erneute ausgangssperre gibt hinzu
kommt dass wichtige versprechen nicht
erfüllt werden als frankreich im
frühjahr corona patienten wegen betten
mangels quer durch das land verschicken
muss kündigt die regierung abhilfe an
wir werden darum jedes jahr bedeutende
mittel bereitstellen um weitere 4.000
krankenhausbetten in betrieb nehmen zu
können
doch schon ein halbes jahr später ist in
einigen städten die sorge zurück dass
intensivbetten knapp werden
wir wissen was in den kommenden fünfzehn
tagen passiert dass wir wieder die
hälfte aller intensivbetten mit cupid
patienten überlegen testergebnisse
lassen auf sich warten die kontakt
verfolgung reicht nicht aus und
gewerkschafter bemängeln dass das
pflegepersonal erschöpft sei wir haben
heute weniger betten als im januar und
wir haben weniger personal als im januar
die wirtschaftlichen folgen der krise
nehmen der regierung handlungsspielraum
der gesundheitsminister droht der stadt
paris wegen steigender infektionszahlen
bars und restaurants zu schließen aber
weil restaurants ein wichtiger
wirtschaftsfaktor sind und die stadt
sich wert werden nur bares geschlossen
was für unverständnis sorgt werden doch
offen bleiben und im sitzen servieren
können
ich sehe nicht wurde unterschied sein
soll zwischen trinken und essen das ist
ungerecht bei all den orten wo menschen
sich noch dicht an dicht versammeln
dürfen was man den behörden vor halten
kann ist dass sie ihrer verantwortung
nicht nachgekommen sind als die
situation sich wieder verschlechtert
es wurde immer gesagt dass die franzosen
die maßnahmen nicht befolgen aber die
ansagen waren auch nicht sehr klar und
verständnis und kritik überall und dann
muss der premierminister auf nachfrage
noch eine peinlichkeit einräumen was die
nationale corona waren app angeht
ich fordere die franzosen auf sie
herunter zu laden aber ich selbst habe
es nicht gemacht
wechselnde rhetorik zickzackkurs
peinlichkeiten frankreichs regierung
verwirrt und empört viele menschen die
zahl der neuinfektionen steigt derweil
weiter zuletzt auf fast 17.000 pro tag